The popping is a result of the walls of the
Rice Krispies kernels fracturing.
There are two prevalent theories as to the
exact process that results in this fracturing
and it’s entirely possible that both are
occurring.
Rice Krispies, also known as “Rice Bubbles”,
in some countries, are created by preparing
rice in such a way that it will “pop”
like popcorn during the cooking process, albeit
much less dramatically.
This popping puffs up the kernels.
When the rice is finished cooking, most of
the Rice Krispies will have thin solid walls
with hollow, sealed, areas inside where air
pockets have formed.
In the first theory of what is causing the
fracturing of the walls, the sudden temperature
shift caused by adding cold milk to the Rice
Krispies causes the air inside the hollow
pockets to contract suddenly, which in turn
fractures the thin walls of the Rice Krispies,
creating the noises.
The second theory also involves the fracturing
of the thin walls, but by a different mechanism.
The thin walls of the Rice Krispies have very
strong bonds between the starch molecules,
due to the high heat the Rice Krispies were
prepared at.
When you add cold milk, the sudden shift of
temperature puts a high amount of stress on
these bonds, due to uneven absorption.
This is actually the exact same thing that
happens when you pour hot water over a frozen
windshield.
This dramatic temperature shift causes both
the glass in the windshield and the walls
of the Rice Krispies to shatter.
While Rice Krispies are puffed by preparing
the kernels with steam to provide the necessary
moisture to the kernels to properly “pop”
them, other methods to puff up rice/corn/wheat/etc
are also possible.
The most popular other method is called “gun
puffing”.
In this method, the kernels are cooked under
high pressure.
When the cooking process is at just the right
stage, given the particular kernel, the pressure
is released, causing the kernel to rapidly
expand.
This method tends to produce a more spongy
end product, rather than crispy, like the
method used
with Rice Krispies.